hallo herzlich willkommen in meine
torten mit er hat es so ein bisschen
noch an meiner stimme ich bin auch etwas
angeschlagen habe meine stimme noch
nicht ganz zurück
aber ich wollte euch heute einfach mal
das video zeigen indem ich beschreibe
wie man trotz stapelt ganz wichtig ist
damit eure torte gut hebt und gut
gestaltet wird dass ihr körper passen
benutzt das sind leicht schauen platten
und ich seid ihr euch jetzt gleich mal
weg da habe ich auch dann wo er die
bekommt bevor ich die cloud jetzt
befehle muss ich sie noch auf eine
tortenplatte setzen
da nehme ich mir ganz gerne diese
kupferplatten das sind leicht schon
platten das habe ich auch schon mal in
einem anderen video gezeigt die gibt es
bei www.artegic.de die schneide ich mir
jetzt auf die passende größe zu da passt
jetzt zum glück meinen tortenboden ganz
gut dann nehme ich mir einfach so einen
kater und schneit es zurecht
eigentlich weiß auch einfacher wenn ich
das da drauf los so kann ich direkt
schneiden und hat damit vor zeichnen
müssen
dann kann ich das hier einfach diese
platten könnte jetzt benutzen um eure
torten darauf an zu richten dass er
leicht einfach auch so den umgang mit
toten sei es ihr können die teilnehmer
an heben sie mit von dann überziehen sie
bestreichen und so weiter das mache ich
generell immer wenn ich von da an torten
mache also nicht nur wenn ich sie jetzt
auch stapler sondern sie dienen einfach
immer sehr gut als grundlage für von
daums torten
ich werde ich jetzt einmal einfach im
schnelldurchlauf zeigen wie ich die
karte mit ghana spiel streiche und dann
eine top darauf fülle und im anschluss
seht ihr dann wie ich eben die fertig
fertig überzogenen trocken dann stapler
hier habe ich mein kate
ich habe das jetzt nur am äußeren rand
mit fondant billig weil ihr die mieter
ja sowieso als die mitte wird eher
bedeckt durch den kuchen und deswegen
mache ich als auch gar kein fondant mehr
drauf außer wenn ich möchte dass dein
land glatt ist dann mache ich eine
komplette front absicht drauf und dann
könnte ich das aus rom gestalten
aber das ist mir jetzt heult sand optik
sein soll möchte ich das ja so
unregelmäßig haben von daher passt es so
hier habe ich meine zwei kuchen dass ich
der untere und obere ich hatte euch ja
bei facebook schon bilder gepostet
es ist einfach zu warm verfolgern und
deswegen die stelle hier einfach ein
paar mal gerissen
aber ich habe ja genug deko und es
später zu kaschieren
die torten die sitzen beide jeweils auf
einer capa platte also hier drunter hier
drunter habe ich eine kupferplatte unter
jeder torte und jetzt braucht ihr noch
so buchenholz in rund und zwar habe ich
hier einmal fünf millimeter das ist ein
dicker und einmal wie viel sinn das
gehalt des in 5 mm dünn und es dicke ist
ein zentimeter buchenholz und zwar müsst
ihr die jetzt gleich als dübel benutzen
und wie ich das mache zeige ich euch
jetzt nehme zu ihrem eine tortenplatte
die habe ich jetzt auf so einen
drehteller gesetzt von ikea und stark
kommt jetzt gleich der erste tor die
erste top drauf und damit die gut
anklebt gebe ich da etwas reißen drauf
das rezept habe ich bereits in meinem
teller keks video gezeigt als ich diese
täler keksdosen gemacht habe einfach
sehr schön dass ich nämlich in
superkleber sehr stabil
also ganz große sachen klebe ich immer
mit dem und kleinere filigranes teppich
immer mit cnc kleber mit superkleber und
da habe ich das rezept in meinem hotel
ihr video mit der pinguine wie ich hier
meine topf
sätze die drauf wenn ihr meint sie sich
acht und einfach drauf fahren lassen
ich habe jetzt eben noch ein bisschen
verrutscht deswegen ist hier bisschen
farbe weg aber die kann ich einfach
wieder drüber insel und jetzt gehts zum
stapeln und zwar nehme ich mir jetzt
hier dieses dünne buchenholz und messe
damit die höhe der torte ab das mache
ich jetzt so ich stelle es hier neben
dran
so gehe hier rein und hab können dass
hier schön abschneiden
ich mache es jetzt einfach mit seiner
kleinen säge einmal am rand entlang und
dann kann es eigentlich schon brechen
und jetzt müsst ihr das je nach größe
der torte ein paar mal machen ich werde
jetzt ich hätte sex stäbchen schneiden
damit die torte einfach stabil sitzt
das ist als längenmaß nehmen jetzt
einfach alle runter segen
jetzt haben die stege meistens hier so
unschöne enden die schleife ich dann
ganz gern noch ab da nehme ich einfach
so eine unbenutzte nagelfeile in der
ganz grobe und schreiten sie ein paar
mal drüber außerdem wirken die stäbchen
ist sowieso ein bisschen kürzer werden
weil ja noch ne körper fertig
und weil er dir da nicht durch schlecht
also könnte auch machen aber braucht ihn
und wenn ihr das dann habt dann putzt
ihr die stäbchen bitte nochmal ab bevor
es sie in die torte reinsteckt einfach
um zu verhindern dass da jetzt track in
die torte kommt und dann einfach noch
mal kontrollieren ob sie alle gleich
lang sind das sätze bei mir so kann ich
jetzt benutzen dann nehme ich mir meine
torte und schaue erst mal wo hier die
mitte ist das geht ganz gut wenn ihr
dasein auskühlt geht darauf gibt da
könnt ihr euch gerne auch mal die mitte
markieren
meine kleine torte gehst darauf kommt
die so groß wie hier also bis da darf so
kommt setzt darauf dass könnt ihr euch
ganz gerne mit einem messer einsetzen
das erleichtert später das auflegen
dabei aufpassen bisschen weniger als
einritzen und hier müssen jetzt die
stäbchen rein dann mache ich jetzt
erstmal außen hier
als verein ich mache jetzt außen 5 in
die mitte mache ich noch etwas versetzt
einen weil später ganz in die mitte noch
ein anderer kommt das grundgerüst steht
da kommt jetzt wieder der kleber drauf
schön in die mitte
das reicht denn da musst du aufpassen
dass es später nicht rausgewählt wenn
ihr zuviel habt die stäbe so reinstecken
jetzt nehme ich mir meine zweite torte
da müsste dann auch mal schauen dass ihr
so die schönen seiten die später vorne
sein sollen dann auch nach vorne bringt
und jetzt hier schön drauf setzen so
wäre die torte jetzt schon fest aber mir
ist es noch zu instabil
deswegen kommt da jetzt noch dieser
dicke stab zum einsatz damit ich mir den
jetzt von ganz unten bis oben ab also
ich leg denn praktisch auf eine
unterseite wieder messe bis oben ab und
setzt es aber wichtig dass ihr nicht bis
ganz oben
das so macht sondern dass ihr ein
bisschen weniger abschneidet und da habe
ich jetzt auch die eine seite schön
abgeschliffen und die andere seite im
selbst schwitzen
so sieht es dann aus
und jetzt geht ihr hier in die miete der
torte die habe ich mir auch markiert
schlecht den stab hinein und der erste
widerstand jetzt ist die kupferplatte
unter dieser torte und da müssen wir es
jetzt einfach durch hämmern
also keine angst da passiert nichts und
jetzt nehme ich mir einfach den stab und
steckt es hier weiter rein
jetzt habt ihr nämlich den staat
praktisch von oben bis unten unten ist
als auch in der cover platte drin von
der unteren pforte und jetzt ist die
torte bombenfest
jetzt hab dann natürlich da oben und
kleines loch aber das wird ihr einfach
mit etwas vom land auf einfach ein
kleines stück nehmen und da reinstecken
und meistens kommt dann sowieso eine
deko darüber wer will kann dass man
nochmal platz streichen
ihr könnt es auch viel saubermachen aber
wie gesagt kommt dabei eine gleiche
decke drauf jetzt ständig mal kuchen
schnell wieder kalt und es war im
prinzip schon
also so stapelt man eine torte wenn ihr
eine mehrstöckige torte habt ist das
gleiche prinzip wie im zweiten geschoss
einfach immer höher werden immer mit
einer körper platte dazwischen und immer
mit buchenholz mit den dübeln arbeiten
da kann ein echt nix schiefgehen wenn
editors später servieren soll wenn es
jetzt fertig ist und ihr wollt nicht von
oben nach unten essen könnte einfach mit
einem messer hier unten rein gehen
die torte anheben runterstellen und dann
können dabei die torte anschneiden
ich hoffe dieses video hilft euch dabei
auch mit orten besser zu schlafen
dieses rundholz was ich dann benutze
bekommt ihr in jedem baumarkt das gibt
es da in allen stärken zu kaufen
wenig trocken für uns zu hause aber dann
benutze ich diesen großen kübel gar
nicht denn da werden ja die trocken da
nicht groß transportiert das heißt diese
große kübel dann von unten bis er von
oben bis unten in die torte gibt benutzt
sich immer dann wenn ich die torten
transport
weil ich dann einfach sichergehen kann
das alles an der stelle bleibt wie ich
eben auf die torte gesetzt habe und
nichts verrutscht und ihr habt ja auch
gesehen dass er eben die torten dann
nicht von oben nach unten essen muss
sondern dass man sie dann schön mit
einem messer anheben kann weg stellen
und dann kann man alle zwei oder drei
jahre vierte neben wie viel lässt dann
eben auch sind gleichzeitig essen und
muss nicht die torte von oben nach unten
runter essen
jetzt wünsche ich euch viel spaß beim
nachmachen wenn ihr fragen habt dürft
ich sie gerne unten in der
kommentarfunktion stellen und dann freue
ich mich aufs nächste mal wenn jetzt
etwas meine stimme schonen und ich werde
ich auch noch zeigen wie man diese
korallen und die unterwasser willst wie
man diese deko herstellt falls sie
interesse habt kann ich auch nochmal so
taucher herstellen
das wäre dann so mein nächstes projekt
jetzt wünsche ich euch erst mal eine
schöne zeit und bis zum nächsten mal